[Music]
off to jail
for steve bannon
poor guy
oh
it's amazing
they don't they they didn't understand
that the the pardon
how pardons work a federal pardon does
not prevent you from being charged in uh
state of like i don't know new york
so steve bannon
arrives arrives at the courthouse
to surrender to prosecutors i think he's
charged with five crimes is that right i
think it's five charges let's let's go
look at here i don't wanna i don't wanna
tell you wrong information here
especially about steve bannon looks like
two counts of money laundering three
counts of conspiracy
and one count of scheming too deep fraud
i mean isn't that just like
i mean really that's like the trump
administration and anyone to do a trump
in general two counts of money honoring
three counts of conspiracy and one count
of scheming to fraud
to defraud
oh
god damn steve bannon you piece of [ __ ]
i'm glad to see though that the um that
the decaying blob of spam
will uh maybe maybe get a decent spam
sandwich
in the jailhouse i don't know do they
let spam eat
spam in the in jailhouse i you know
you've seen this picture right a picture
of the decaying moldy piece of spam
it looks like bannon
that's the
scabby steve
scabby steve now
this is uh
on top of
the contempt
and indictment charges and conviction
this is on top of that
this is not um
part of that this is an addition to that
so now steve bannon's not only charged
indicted and convicted in a federal
court now he's surrendering to
prosecutors
in a state court now
to be perfectly honest
if they give him jail time
for the federal charge of contempt of
congress he'll serve that sentence
whatever it is if they give him a prison
sentence he'll go serve that federal
time
while he's awaiting trial for these
state charges because he's not going to
go to trial on these state charges right
away now i i haven't heard if they're
going to an hour ago is when now we got
news of the charges
but uh we haven't heard if they're going
to detain him which they should [ __ ]
detain him [ __ ] that guy he's got
federal charges he's got state charges
now the guy is grifting all over his
[ __ ] his trader news network thing
that he does
every single day
where he's defrauding and scheming to
defraud
his viewers and americans
so and i'm i'm sure i'm sure steve
bannon being good at money laundering
that he is learning from the best donald
trump that he's still doing that as well
these people are not stopping criming
they're not stopping this that's why
that's why the cheeto dust mobster so
pissed off this morning at the lincoln
project did you see this the lincoln
the lincoln
the lincoln project puts a [ __ ] ad on
fox news
uh you call it fox news they put an ad
on on faux news
and he's [ __ ] pissed he's [ __ ]
pissed because lincoln project pointed
out the [ __ ]
fraud frauding scheme
that trump laid on his supporters in
2020 and they all [ __ ] fell for it
the save america pact and [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] legal defense fund and save me
from my enemy fund whatever the [ __ ] it
is that he's doing whatever whatever
money laundering scheme that he's
committing on his supporters and these
brainwashed sheep keep sending in their
their [ __ ] social security checks and
their house payments to this fat slob
why i don't know
even mitch mcconnell yesterday that
[ __ ] coward wouldn't even comment on
donald trump's investigation
and how he stole
our top secret documents that apparently
include
the new clear secrets of a foreign
government
oh jesus [ __ ] christ
mitch mcconnell wouldn't even he's like
nope uh um i'm not gonna talk about that
because uh he's going to jail i mean i
mean they're they're terrified as
geraldo geraldo this morning geraldo
scary haraldo this morning
geraldo rivera
is like no [ __ ] trump [ __ ] him he's done
he's going to
steve bannon's going to jail donald
trump's going to jail cash patel's
probably going to jail we're probably
gonna mark meadows peter navarro
john eastman jeffrey clark christina bob
i mean the list goes on and on and on
here folks
on and on and on and on and that is one
reason why
one reason why
trump looks so damn stupid is because he
has no one around him anymore
they've all really abandoned him i mean
don't go out on tv and act like they
love him they'll do that because he
loves that oh [ __ ] he loves when they
get on tv and act like they [ __ ] love
him oh he [ __ ]
that's his thing
but i mean how hard is it to go on tv
a lie i mean these people are easy
easily go on tv and lie
i mean stephen miller
kellyanne conway and the like of course
he'll go on [ __ ] tv and live for this
son of a [ __ ] jesus christ even bill
barr won't won't do it anymore
because see bill barr knows he's going
to jail but bill barr doesn't give a
[ __ ] what does bill barr care
bill bart's part of the da old darth
vader republican party the cheney types
right
billboard doesn't give a [ __ ]
hell bill bart got his he got his book
he's not going to be he's not going to
be held accountable for how he buried
the mueller report he's not going to be
held accountable for that he knows that
what the [ __ ] he care what the hell
does he care he's moved on he didn't
commit any crimes when it comes to a
coup he got out but when the getting was
good baby
that's why bill bard's doing what he's
doing it's like [ __ ] this guy
but we see steve bannon being toted into
the courthouse i'm gonna show the video
i'm gonna show the video of this lady
just absolutely incinerating steve
bannon
as he's walking into the courthouse
and this this i don't know who this is
bless her heart whoever this lady is in
new york city absolutely yelling and
screaming at steve bannon holding a sign
and destroying him as he walks into the
white house and he tries to play victim
of course of course he does he plays
victim as he walks into the courthouse
talking about how
the the mayor of new york city has sent
a a group of people down to the border
and to texas to tell greg abbott hey
stop human trafficking people to our
state you [ __ ] human trafficker stop
doing it if you're gonna do it let's
organize with it
stop trafficking humans you piece of
[ __ ] greg abbott
so they sent people down there and he's
complaining oh i'm a victim my name's
steve bannon i'm a trump supporter and
i'm a victim
like yeah no [ __ ] sherlock we know we
know you think
you're a [ __ ] victim and you're
persecuted
oh but nothing's better
than the smell of six
six counts
in new york state this morning
on scabby steve bannon we also have news
that the uh the queen of england queen
elizabeth
ii uh is sick apparently she's
recovering from something there's not a
lot of news um it seems like they're
warning the world that
you know i mean she is 96 she's been the
queen for like a thousand years
you know one thing i do want to say
about this
is that queen elizabeth really has the
perspective of that not a lot of folks
have this perspective and what i mean by
this is she was the queen
she was the queen
during a time where she watched
nazi not germany turned into nazi
germany
she was there
she was there now there were a lot of
people there but they weren't the queen
for crying out loud of a country who was
being bombed
bombed by nazi germany
and now she sees the world turn to this
far right fascism we have these
far-right fascists crawling out
underneath their rocks
here in america they're the america
first let's go brandon nazis but there
there's factions all around the world
and this is this really is an infection
and a disease
that is spreading rapidly um the
internet is a hell of a tool
it's a hell of a way to communicate all
around the world in an instant and a
second
and this is the reason why
we are having some of this trouble is
because we're still trying to figure
this out we're in the
infancy of
of communication over the internet and
what the effects are on society
and we we've watched
as
in this country close up some people
closer than others i mean i i'm here in
missouri where
it's kind of trump country
and i have relatives that have fallen to
this this maga delusion
that somehow the world's out to get them
and
most people refer to it as
maca but there's also this q anon
faction
and this brainwashing where steve bannon
can go and
talk about i think it's called we build
the wall i believe that is what the
[ __ ]
the fund is called as we build a wall
and this [ __ ] can just
say out in the universe hey give me your
money we'll go build a wall and we'll
stop the brown people from coming in our
country right
like that's that's the thing that steve
bannon tries to do and bam they
with the delusion and the right-wing
media just pumping this garbage into
their brains every day they they do not
hesitate to give steve bannon their
their house payment
their social security check
and steve bannon he's like yeah a
million bucks hell yeah i'll put that
right in my pocket [ __ ] them because
what they don't know is steve bannon
doesn't give a [ __ ] about that wall he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about that wall he
doesn't give a [ __ ] if
if brown people come in the country he
doesn't care if people cross the border
he in fact wants people to cross the
border
he wants them to cross the border so he
has a demon to sell to to his masses
so that he can collect and grift more
money this is why they're really [ __ ]
in a pickle here with roe
they're really in a [ __ ] pickle with
roe
it's it's you know they say it's like
the dog who caught the car but really
it's the dog who tried to catch the car
and the [ __ ] car ran right over him
because that's that's that's what is
happening here
is that the republican party is finally
starting to figure out oh [ __ ] well i
mean if if we get real overturned
the only way for us to campaign is to go
even further right
to convince these these delusional
people that we're gonna ban abortion
everywhere
you saw it with with laura windsor last
week with one of these candidates he he
he stepped over himself but he
absolutely said yes we will have a
federal ban
because that's what they want to do they
want to take away your [ __ ] rights
that's what these right-wingers want to
do and they use all kinds of excuses
they use all kinds of great stories
to do that
one of them is we build a wall yeah but
trump's well just elect trump he'll
build a wall he's elected well i can't
build a wall so go give steve bannon
your [ __ ] money and we'll pocket your
money that way the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ]
it's just nonsense absolute nonsense but
the greatest part about it all the
greatest part about it all is they're
being exposed right out in the open and
this morning no better time than this
morning where steve bannon's walking
into the courthouse acting like he's the
[ __ ] victim when he [ __ ] stole a
million dollars worth of his supporters
money
that [ __ ] [ __ ] and then you have
donald trump donald trump this morning
whining and crying
on his fraud social about a [ __ ] ad
that lincoln project aired on fox
news if you want to call it news it's
not
if you want to call it that
this morning he's
he's posting on
on fraud social that
i'm gonna sue the link of course he's
gonna sue the lincoln project is what he
says get the [ __ ] out of here okay sue
them for what for telling the truth to
your [ __ ] supporters on a tv on a
trade or tv network that they're gonna
view and they're gonna see this ad yeah
okay try it i'd love to see the
discovery of that one
i'd love to see the discovery in that
case
and of course lincoln project is
probably gonna dare him to sue him
but he's really mad he's really mad this
morning that steve bannon is charged
with this uh we build a wall fraud
because it was always a fraud from the
very beginning when he came down a
[ __ ] golden escalator and started
demonizing people of color
that that was it that was the [ __ ]
fraud from the very beginning
and then they started chanting bill wall
and it went on and on and on and on and
here we are steve bannon
donald trump's right-hand man his
[ __ ] campaign ceo or whatever the
[ __ ] his title was whatever the [ __ ] his
title was when in 2016 when they were
colluding with russia to try to take
over our [ __ ] government
but here we have
donald trump and steve bannon really
pissed off this morning playing victim
which is not surprising
because
their frauds are coming to light
the other fraud that's coming to light
is is the right-wing media attacking
hillary clinton for for for calling
people deplorable and it's oh this is
this was setting up joe biden to call
people fascist as if as if that was the
goal you are fascist you are [ __ ]
nazis what are you what do you want from
us what do you want us to do you want us
to be nice to you no we are intolerant
of intolerance that is what we're going
to do the left has had enough of this
[ __ ] we've had enough of your crybaby
little fascist snowflake [ __ ] and we're
not putting up with it anymore we are
not going to be tolerant of intolerance
it's enough you can sit down and shut
the [ __ ] up
but hillary clinton makes a debut on the
view about this issue and fox news and
the rest of the right-wing media losing
their minds
that all they're demonizing people yeah
we are we're that's exactly what we're
doing we're demonizing people who are
are intolerant
of other human beings that is exactly
and we are going to politicize it that's
exactly what we're going to do
because that's really what they want
they keep calling like there's going to
be violence over this [ __ ] document
thing where the the former guy the
cheeto dust mobster
stole our [ __ ] documents our
government documents he stole top secret
foreign government nuclear secrets get
the [ __ ] out of here and and we're not
gonna if we indict him you guys are
gonna commit violence yeah okay that's
not what they're gonna do they're not
that the threat of violence is not the
huge threat the threat here is that they
take over our governments
that is the [ __ ] real threat and
that's what you have to realize that's
what you have to do and engage in your
democracy and it's not just about
marking your ballot because you have the
power of the ballot you do have that
power but you can register folks to vote
still in some states you need to check
your registration to make sure it is
still good so you do have the power of
your ballot because let me tell you if
you live in a state that where a
republican has control over anything boy
they're really trying to take your
[ __ ] vote away from you you goddamn
right because they know you're going to
vote against fascism and that is not
something they want they definitely want
you to not vote if you hate fascists
hate them
like in florida or georgia
pennsylvania ohio they know it's coming
this morning they're talking about on
right-wing media these trader tv news
networks they're going to talk about
kevin mccarthy's going to release a
great plan really that's what you're
banking on
is kevin mccarthy releasing a plan
apparently kevin mccarthy is going to be
the new newt gingrich did you know newt
gingrich is still alive holy [ __ ] how
old is this guy i thought he was he's
gotta be older than queen elizabeth
jesus christ this [ __ ] guy newt
gingrich but apparently kevin mccarthy
is gonna be the new newt gingrich she's
gonna release a great plan that's going
to deliver the house for republicans
and it's all a distraction it's all a
distraction that's what that is
you do not need to play this game when
you're out there engaging in your
democracy you do not need to play the
game of trying to go on defense of what
kevin mccarthy's plan is guess what if
we tell them to [ __ ] off his plan
doesn't mean hell iota [ __ ] that plan
you can say [ __ ] that plan when you go
vote
that's what you can do
that's how you can do this you don't
have to play the game of talking to
someone about it even
hell i'm gonna crush it here on our show
when he releases this thing
every single thing i'm gonna [ __ ]
just destroy
because you know it's gonna be
destroyable they're republicans they're
fascists they're moglodites of course
it's gonna be easy to destroy their
little new
plan newt gingrich 2.0
that was [ __ ] 30 years ago
30 years ago
30 years ago newt gingrich
had this great plan they took back the
house that's their plan here
rick scott was supposed to be in charge
of that for the senate he [ __ ] that up
oh baby oh baby did rick's got [ __ ]
that up he's like yeah we want to take
away your medicare and take away your
social security and on top of that we
don't want women to have rights
oh great one great job great job with
the messaging there rick thank you so
politicize it
now they're going to have kevin mccarthy
of all people
unveil a great plan that we're going to
be able to destroy and again this is
only gonna give people more reason to go
vote against these [ __ ]
you know you know this [ __ ] is not gonna
talk about democracy
you know this [ __ ] is not gonna talk
about making sure school children start
at an age of three instead of five you
know this is not going to talk about
average working american families
getting relief from student debt relief
nope not going to talk about that this
plan is definitely not going to talk
about you you going [ __ ] bankrupt
over a medical bill hell to the no it's
not there's no way in hell this plan
talks about anything americans want
it'll it'll [ __ ] talk about sexy
green m m's woke culture disney's woke
and and and there's being and fentanyl
being seized at the border
as if that's a bad thing
that's what it will be
about and we will crush it we will
politicize it
because folks we got him on the run and
we gotta lean into this we gotta lean
into this [ __ ] we really do
we can't stop now now that we feel like
oh well we're gonna take the senate we
probably gonna take the house nope
lean way into it [ __ ] them
joe biden the president united states
called them fascist
he's leaning into rallying democracy and
you must lean into rallying democracy
too so have that strategic outrage
go use your power of your ballot and
engage in your democracy lean into it
lean way into it
because they're coming for your way of
life
and they're doing it in all sorts of
crazy ways and i have someone on the
show today that wants to talk about how
that is happening what is happening
you've noticed i
i hear lately
the cheeto dust mobster the former guy
has just absolutely been going bonkers
on fraud social i mean some of these
[ __ ] these little posts that he does
i mean you can't even hardly read the
son of a [ __ ] they're so [ __ ]
crazy and out there but the one thing
that is significant that a lot of people
aren't paying attention to is he's been
retweeting a lot of q anon stuff it's
almost like to me and maybe we'll ask
our guest here
it's it's almost like to me what donald
trump is trying to do
is trying to really
reinvigorate
these conspiracy theories reinvigorate
this stochastic type terrorism to try to
get not just not just the oath keepers
and the proud boys but just average
everyday delusional americans who
believe this queuing on stuff
to get them to save him because you
remember in december of 2020 when he
knew he lost the state certified the
votes those votes were going to come to
washington
they were looking for the electorate the
electorate college in washington but
they couldn't find it
but when they when the vote came on
january 6 for them to certify those
states votes he was calling on those
people he was so desperately wanting
them to save him from indictments to
save him from not being president
because he knew the risk he knew it and
that's what he's doing again when he's
cat-calling these [ __ ] delusional
crazy q and honors
is he setting this up
to where
he can get them
to save him and we're going to talk to
jim stewartson right here about this
issue when we come back we've i'm going
to talk about his film we're going to
talk about his film that he has on q
anon you have to go watch this film the
link is down in the description so after
the show go check it out you can also
check out his sub stack but stick around
we're going to talk to jim right after
these messages don't go anywhere we'll
be right back